no
[Música]
ah
i
buenas tardes muchas gracias de verdad
muchas gracias a todos por estar acabo
voy a empezar haciendo un par de
preguntas quiénes de ustedes han
escuchado que colombia es uno de los
países más felices del mundo levanten la
mano todos y ahora a quien cree que vive
en el país más feliz del mundo
ya no son tantos preguntas como éstas me
las hice en el 2013 después de leer en
muchos reportes que colombia era uno de
los países más felices del mundo no
entendía ni qué preguntaban ni a quién
le preguntaban para llegar a una
conclusión de felicidad tan alta en un
país con unos niveles de corrupción
desigualdad y pobreza tan altos como los
que vivimos
yo soy académica y uno de los inmensos
privilegios que tiene estar en la
academia es que uno tiene herramientas
conceptuales y metodológicas para
responderse a este tipo de preguntas y
así fue como hice desde el 2013 mi
principal tema de investigación
lo primero que hice preguntar al iniciar
la investigación fue preguntarme qué es
lo que pregunta a los rankings de
felicidad en el mundo y me encontré que
todos los rankings en el mundo no
necesariamente preguntan sobre felicidad
sino que preguntan sobre un concepto que
se llama satisfacción con la vida me voy
a tomar un momento estar en esta
distinción
la felicidad es una emoción y es un
estado que cambia en función del día si
usted hoy fue y se comió un helado con
sus amigos va a ser muy feliz pero si en
la noche se queda atascado en tráfico su
nivel de felicidad va a disminuir pero
la satisfacción con la vida es mucho más
que eso es una valoración del punto en
el que estamos de qué tan valioso
creemos que es lo que hacemos y el
recorrido la valoración al recorrido que
le damos a nuestras vidas
muchos de estos rankings internacionales
no miden felicidad sino satisfacción con
la vida y esa es una distinción
importante la segunda pregunta que me
hice es
disculpe esto estaba como me devuelvo
perdón me anticipé
la segunda pregunta que me hice fue a
quién le importa cuál es la relevancia
de saber si un país es más feliz que
otro
por qué es importante gastarse los
recursos en hacer ese tipo de
investigación y hemos encontrado que los
países en vías de los países
desarrollados eeuu y japón por ejemplo
el ingreso per cápita ha aumentado
durante los últimos años pero los
niveles de felicidad en la población no
lo han hecho de la misma forma
entonces no necesariamente el indicador
principal por el que miden los gobiernos
que es crecimiento económico no aumenta
la felicidad en la gente y qué pasa
cuando los niveles de felicidad en la
población disminuyen
esto es lo que sucede la gráfica que les
estoy mostrando es la relación entre el
ingreso per cápita y los niveles de
felicidad en egipto la línea amarilla
muestra cómo se ha mantenido de manera
sostenida el ingreso per cápita desde el
2005 y la línea blanca muestra como los
niveles de felicidad han disminuido y en
el momento en que se encuentra la mayor
los menores reportes de felicidad
aparece la primavera
esta misma gráfica y esta misma
tendencia se ha reportado en el reino
unido con el break city
más recientemente en méxico disculpen en
chile con las manifestaciones de la
población y dado los resultados de las
últimas elecciones y en lo que pasó la
semana pasada para qué pasó hace dos
días en colombia yo no dudaría que en
algún momento empezáramos a ver esta
tendencia en cali y en colombia
esto es a lo que yo me dedico a estudiar
las estadísticas subjetivas las
estadísticas son subjetivas lo que miden
son los niveles de satisfacción que
tenemos nosotros con las cosas que
hacemos las estadísticas objetivas por
ejemplo las tasas de empleo miden todo
pero no miden las cosas que valen la
pena ser medidas las tasas de empleo le
dicen cuántas personas hay empleadas en
la ciudad de cali pero no le dicen si la
gente está contenta con lo que hace y
aquí es donde aparece en las
estadísticas subjetivas y la necesidad
de incluirlas en los sistemas de
medición de los países con este panorama
en el 2014 iniciamos un proyecto de
investigación
la universidad icesi en el observatorio
de políticas públicas iniciamos una
encuesta poblacional que denominamos
calibrando y es el primer sistema de
medición de bienestar subjetivo en una
ciudad en colombia y el mejor de nuestro
conocimiento en américa latina'
nosotros queremos saber qué tan felices
son los caleños que los hace felices y
fundamentalmente qué relación tiene el
gobierno con nuestra felicidad
individual eso es lo que les vengo a
hablar en el día de hoy pero antes de
mostrarle los resultados voy a empezar
por esta pregunta en una escala de 0 a
10 que tan satisfechos están ustedes con
su vida
piensa en es un momento póngale un
número a la escala
y listo
si usted es como el colombiano y como el
caleño promedio usted le puso de esa
escala 8.5 y eso es muy alto los países
desarrollados a esa misma pregunta los
ciudadanos le ponen un puntaje promedio
de 6.5 por eso es que somos uno de los
países más felices del mundo por los
niveles tan altos en los que reportamos
eso pero qué es lo que nos hace tan
feliz
el primer factor que explica nuestra
felicidad individual es la salud no hay
un factor más importante explicando la
felicidad individual que el estado de
salud propio y el de la familia
cuando empezamos a estudiar los
diferentes indicadores que tenemos de
salud nos encontramos disparidades muy
grandes por género los hombres son los
que reportan tener mejor salud física
que las mujeres y las disparidades son
muy importantes incluso la salud mental
de las mujeres en cali es menor que la
de los hombres el 21 por ciento de las
mujeres en cali manifestó sentirse sola
en el 2018
y aún más existen disparidades también
por estrato socioeconómico y existen
también dobles discriminaciones las
mujeres y las mujeres más pobres son las
que reportan mayor prevalencia de
ansiedad estrés depresión y reportado
una peor salud física otra de las cosas
que hemos encontrado es que la gente
asocia un buen estado de salud con
ausencia del dolor
cerca del 50% de la población en cali
tiene sobrepeso u obesidad pero ellos
dicen que están divinamente de salud
es más el 40 por ciento de la gente con
sobrepeso u obesidad está satisfecha con
su peso actual eso es uno no darse
cuenta que el sobrepeso de la obesidad
es la cuota inicial para una enfermedad
crónica
el segundo factor que nos hace muy
felices son las relaciones afectivas y
prepárense para escuchar noticias que
pueden ser nuevas o que pueda sonar
contra intuitivas lo primero es que la
gente casada es más feliz y eso pasa en
cali en colombia y en todo el mundo la
gente casada incluso es mucho más feliz
que la gente que vive en cohabitación
osea que sea repuntan si se quiere
cuando hacemos análisis sobre la
satisfacción en las relaciones afectivas
también encontramos diferencias por
género uno un hombre le dice califique
de 0 a 10 la calidad de su relación
afectiva un hombre dice 8.3 le hace la
misma pregunta a una mujer y ella dice
7.4 es más hace poco estaba hablando con
un investigador que me estaba contando
que había un nuevo reporte que mostraba
que los hombres se dan cuenta de la
noticia del divorcio en el momento en
que la mujer les pide el divorcio
mientras que las mujeres llevan en
promedio dos años cocinando la idea
les voto el dato les debe ese pedazo de
información
los amigos y la familia son muy
importantes explicando nuestra felicidad
la familia extensa es muy importante
entre más personas vivan en el hogar en
el que convivimos más felices vamos a
hacer y lo mismo aplica para los amigos
los hijos no hacen más feliz a la gente
los hijos por el contrario aumentan las
tasas de ansiedad depresión y estrés
entre los padres y las tasas son mucho
más altas entre las mujeres que entre
los hombres pero los hijos dan propósito
que es una dimensión completamente
diferente
el tercer factor que no explican
nuestros altos niveles de felicidad es
el optimismo y la percepción de ascenso
social y en esto los caleños están
haciendo un muy buen trabajo la mayoría
de los caleños creen que están mejor que
el año pasado y que el año entrante van
a estar incluso mejor y este nivel de
optimismo es incluso más alto entre las
poblaciones más pobres y eso es
justamente la definición del optimismo y
es creer que vamos a estar mejor no como
consecuencia de las condiciones actuales
sino a pesar de las condiciones actuales
pero los datos objetivos muestran que
hay razones para estar más optimistas un
caleño promedio tiene acumulado 11.3
años de educación que es muy poco pero
ha estudiado en promedio 8 años más que
sus padres y eso es ascenso social eso
es movilidad social entonces no es
solamente percepción de optimismo es que
en realidad las cosas dentro de todo
están mejor
y dentro de todo esto que tanto importa
el gobierno deje amenazarles otra
pregunta quién de ustedes pensó en el
alcalde cuando hizo el cálculo de
satisfacción con la vida
uno para allá
pero esto es esto es lo que nosotros nos
llevábamos siempre la gente no piensa en
el gobierno cuando piensa su felicidad y
no hace los cálculos de lo que hace o no
hace el gobierno y esa es una de las
grandes diferencias con los países
desarrollados la gente si piensa en el
gobierno lo que hace en el gobierno
nadie se da cuenta una persona no es más
feliz por recibir un subsidio para
reducción de pobreza posiblemente porque
ser beneficiario de un subsidio para
reducir la pobreza muestra todo lo que
está haciendo mal el gobierno aunque
tengo que hacer la clarificación que los
jóvenes que han sido beneficiarios de
becas para acceder a la educación
superior si son más felices posiblemente
porque eso muestra los valores que
nosotros como sociedad queremos promover
lo que hace mal el gobierno por el
contrario si disminuyen nuestros niveles
de felicidad particularmente las tasas
de crimen y el tráfico eso disminuye la
felicidad de la gente en calle
una de las primeras conclusiones a las
que nosotros hemos llegado haciendo esta
investigación es que la felicidad en
cali es individual la gente está feliz
con sus relaciones afectivas está feliz
en su hogar con el trabajo que tienen
pero esa felicidad no se transfiere en
proyectos colectivos una de las
principales razones por las que la gente
llama a la línea 123 es a quejarse por
el ruido del vecino eso es un ejemplo de
como la felicidad es individual y no es
colectiva nosotros somos un país donde
necesitamos un código de policía para
que la gente sea amonestado por no
recoger los residuos de su mascota
eso es un ejemplo de felicidad
individual y de no felicidad colectiva
eso es no pensar que como sociedad
tenemos que construir nos y tejer el
tejido que nos va a sostener y que va a
hacer que como sociedad nuestro gobierno
y nuestra sociedad
camps
ahora que nos hace falta para ser más
felices
piensa en el momentico
que necesitan para llegar al 10 en la
escala
si ustedes son como los caleños y los
colombianos ustedes pensaron en plata o
en cualquier cosa que se compre con
plata un viaje un carro una casa todo lo
que sea aproximación de dinero
la relación entre dinero y felicidad
existe es lineal es positiva pero la
plata solo importa cuando las
necesidades básicas no están satisfechas
en el momento en que sus recursos le
permiten llenar todas sus necesidades la
plata deja de importar y realmente en la
fórmula de la felicidad el peso que
tiene el dinero es muy poquito es más
hay un momento en que un peso más no
compra más felicidad nosotros hemos
estimado hemos estimado el punto de
inflexión donde la plata no da más
felicidad de cali y esta es la
estimación son 6 millones de pesos
es posible que haya gente que tenga ese
salario o que tengan ese ingreso
combinado en sus hogares y muy
posiblemente el dinero no los va a ser
más felices
pero los estratos más bajos donde vive
el 55% de la población en calle y donde
el ingreso es de 900 mil pesos mensuales
se necesitan casi 7 adultos en un hogar
para llegar a ese ingreso y eso muestra
las profundas inequidades que hay en
esta ciudad y hay una correlación mucho
más alta entre crimen e inequidad que
crimen y pobreza es muy probable que sea
la inequidad que tenemos en la ciudad lo
que explique fenómenos como los que
pasaron hace dos días más que la pobreza
entre modos de estudio sobre la
felicidad y en estos seis años que llevo
haciendo esta investigación con mi
equipo de polis y gracias por estar acá
muchas de mis preferencias han cambiado
para mí hoy no hay nada más importante
que la calidad de las relaciones que
construyó con mi familia con mis amigos
con mi pareja y les agradezco que ésta
no vaya a cabo la salud oa cuido con una
dieta balanceada con el ejercicio y el
dinero que en algún momento fue una
métrica de éxito para mis estándares hoy
le ha replanteado tremendamente hay
gente que es mucho más feliz con menos
de lo que yo tengo es más la gente más
pobre en cali en la que reportar los
niveles de felicidad más altos
lo que he aprendido en esta
investigación intento llevarlo a las
aulas de clase mis estudiantes son
jóvenes de 20 años que tiene una
prevalencia muy alta de estrés y
ansiedad por tratar de conseguir lo que
ellos creen que los va a ser feliz y es
un trabajo que les de mucho dinero que
los lleva a viajar alrededor del mundo y
que tengan que pueden postear las fotos
en redes sociales que ellos ven eso no
los va a ser más feliz los niveles de
felicidad dentro de la población más
joven son los más bajos porque los
jóvenes no han aprendido a mirar hacia
atrás ellos solo miran hacia adelante y
están pensando que la felicidad se va a
conseguir en el momento que consigan la
meta que ellos creen que los va a ser
más feliz y no han aprendido a mirar
hacia atrás y valorar el camino que han
podido recorrer
hoy estoy completamente convencida que
una cátedra de felicidad debería ser
obligatoria en el sistema de educativo y
en esta clase se debería enseñar sobre
generosidad sobre compasión
debido a la tercera generosidad
compasión
y agradecimiento una persona que tiene
los recursos para pagar lo justo de sus
empleados si no lo hace no se le ha
enseñado a ser generoso en un país tan
violento como el que vivimos una persona
que sea capaz de hacerle daño físico a
otra por un celular o por una bicicleta
no se le ha enseñado de compasión y un
estudiante que está en el sistema
educativo superior y no de lo mejor que
tiene en cada clase no se le ha enseñado
a ser agradecida y estos son valores que
se enseñan y que no solamente de
responsabilidad del hogar esto también
la responsabilidad del sistema educativo
en esta clase también se debe enseñar
sobre proyectos colectivos en algún
momento tenemos que dejar de pensar
individualmente y tenemos que dejar de
pensar en nuestra felicidad en la esfera
estrictamente privada cada llamada que
hacemos a la línea 123 oa la policía
para quejarnos del mal comportamiento de
los vecinos esos son recursos públicos
mal invertidos porque muestra que no
somos capaces de autorregular nos como
sociedad
los invito para que cuando piensen en
que los va a ser más felices piense en
agradecimiento sean más agradecidos por
lo que tienen y por las personas que
tienen alrededor y el agradecimiento son
actos no son palabras si ustedes quieren
ser agradecidos con sus padres tenés
tiempo de calidad saque tiempo de vayan
el almuerzo con sus amigos respondan el
email devuelvan las llamadas cuiden el
tono de la voz y la escogencia de las
palabras cuando hablen con las personas
que quieren involucres en en su
comunidad donde en tiempo hagan algo en
lo que ustedes crean que puedan
construir una mejor sociedad mientras
piensan de qué manera pueden incorporar
esto en su vida no dejen de jugar la
lotería que de pronto se la gana
gracias
[Aplausos]